[Music]
one of the things i raised and others
raised i wasn't the only one
who raises the g7 is that
[Music]
we don't know we haven't had access to
the laboratories to determine
whether or not i have not reached a
conclusion because our intelligence
community is
not certain yet whether or not this was
a consequence there is an enormous
amount of evidence
that there was a leak from the wilhelm
institute of virology there's a
there's a pile of evidence a hundred
feet high do you
believe that the virus
came from a lab league from the wuhan
institute
i do all right so mike pompeo thinks it
was from a lab leak
but his progress with the president
because for the longest time a lot of
democrats pooh-poohed the whole idea of
the lab leak
dan bongino never did he is the host of
the dan bongino show streaming daily on
fox nation and host of
unfiltered with dan bongino a big hit on
saturday nights here on fox news
dan good morning to you morning good
morning thanks for that uh promotion
there i appreciate it it's been
a real joy doing the show it's great to
have you as a part of the fox family of
course
so so what do you make of this uh the
way
joe biden has evolved on the lab leak
yeah yeah i love how they evolved from
it was a total conspiracy and you're all
wackos too
then some mainstream media coverage gets
out there where people finally wake up
to the fact that this may be real
the entire time and now it's called an
evolution and that's not an evolution
what an evolution steve would be
is hey we don't have the information yet
let's make an informed
fact data point-based decision that's
not what they did
what they said is people like you me and
others at the network who are open
open to alternate explanations they call
this wackos and kooks and conspiracy
theories
social media accounts for i mean lock
people out of social media
so you know again that the leftist let's
not pretend that this was some kind of
oh we were just trying to wait and see
you weren't and by the way guys the
evidence was everywhere you know i went
through it on my saturday night show on
fox
i went through it piece by piece in a
12-minute monologue you know these
viruses guys they have a code
just like a computer code made up of
bases cytosine guanine these other
things you don't have to be a
advanced scientist to figure this out
this double cgg
code in the corona virus in covert 19 we
have not
found it in nature anywhere doesn't mean
it doesn't exist
we have not found it but you know where
we have found it
with lab researchers who insert that
code in gain of function research
to make these viruses super viruses that
is in
covid19 and you know what's really
convenient the wuhan lab researcher who
got
money from the eco health alliance and
the taxpayer omitted that double cgg
code in her analysis of the virus so
that no one would see it
hey dan and again the evidence was
everywhere dan what can we do
if this is true and it was a lab leak
what do we do to hold china
accountable we need to expand
a magnitsky type sanction against
chinese government officials
and their regime it's what we've done
against you know russian oligarchs were
involved in the killing of magnitsky
i mean you should not be allowed to have
you or your kids anywhere in the country
if you're part of a communist regime
that unleashed this pandemic that killed
millions of people
it would stop it right away they said
guys you gotta remember they send their
kids to college here too
that's what's really going to hurt they
have bank accounts here a lot of these
people
money follow the money every single time
you want to sting
that's what that would sting big time
yeah also they become spies here which
is fascinating
and a lot of the private colleges want
the chinese money so they're going to go
to bat to make sure they're never banned
from the campus
uh we've seen that that's part of the
strategy
yeah look at the confucius institutes i
mean listen there's been a big chinese
propaganda effort within the united
states
for years you know i played at the end
of my monologue in the saturday show
yuri besmanoff a soviet defector in 1982
who warned about this infiltrate the
educational apparatus in the country and
you'll destroy the population from the
inside out it's not hard to do we were
warned we just didn't listen
you're right about that all right uh dan
thank you very much for joining us live
from
i believe you're down in florida have a
great podcast
and radio show and we'll see you soon
thank you dan thanks guys